thankfully we turn to some lighter news
crippling gambling addiction in
Singapore at the start of this year's
World Cup which of course Germany one
Singapore produced a powerful
anti-gambling commercial see if you can
spot it's one fatal flaw I really can't
wait for the World Cup who thing's gonna
win it by that's what Brazil we win
about you Andy I hope German you mean
why when they bet all my savings on them
[Music]
no but Germany won't fight that kid is
now the richest sad person since Crispin
is Stewart clearly clearly this was a
little awkward so Singapore actually
created a second ad where the boy is
asked your dad's team won did you get
your savings back to which he responds
no dad never stops he wants to bet one
more time but yeah of course he does but
guys on a hot streak
the only thing that can stop that is
your negative attitude you ungrateful
little now interestingly Singapore
actually has a long history of blowing
it with their anti-gambling
advertisements just just take a look I
hope the Seahawks win the Super Bowl
my dad bet all our savings on them good
luck there's no way a second-year
quarterback and beating future
hall-of-famer Peyton Manning your dad's
a complete zero I'm gonna be homeless
and die in a shopping cart
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the matter auntie my dad bet all
our savings again on California chrome
to win this year's Triple Crown no he
has to win the Kentucky Derby and
Preakness but then get fourth place in
the Belmont Stakes
Wow that's a very specific thing I know
it's never gonna happen for bridgie oh
you mean white hot stone massage to 3:30
Thank You forbid you show guys my dad's
out of control shut up Andy yes shut up
wait this time my dad bet everything we
have that in the first half of the
second week of July news will break that
Ryan Gosling will have impregnated Ava
Mendez and that they're expecting a baby
in October
[Music]
[Applause]
the big lesson from Singapore is very
terrible
unless dad is really feeling it
[Applause]